I want to know if you want to know about
my book so I'm super excited because I'm
in the final stages of signing a deal
with the major publisher to get my book
out and I was wondering if you guys
wanted to join me along my process of
writing and publishing and marketing a
book what I was thinking was a weekly or
every two weeks or every three weeks
depending on my progress video sharing
how I'm doing what I'm writing about my
thoughts my concerns the process of
creating the book what my editor is
saying trying to make it as open as
possible without getting in trouble with
the powers that be that I'm working with
and so I'm wondering is that helpful for
you would you want to learn with me
along the process and journey or would
you rather just know when it's out and
say you know tell make a video about
when the book is that what it's all
about we don't we don't want to know the
journey I'm really curious so the
choices i only make two videos a day on
the channel right and so if i'm making
this video talking about my book and my
progress and the ups and downs then
that's one less question that I'm
answering from you guys so I'm really
curious to find out what do you think
would you rather hear about my book and
the progress that's happening there and
the issues i'm going through or would
you rather say forget about that just
answer our questions and let me know
leave a comment below and your choices
will help me decide what to do continue
to believe thank you for your feedback
and i'll see you soon